ces bruits
salut les amis disent pas que vous
passez de bonnes vacances
salut c'est jason
adams je te demande pas si je connais
end aux
touristes
acteur producteur scénariste
vous l'a toujours que les tickets du
jeune qui s'est fait pistonné etc par
qui je sais pas pourtant c'est un mets
qui s'est créée en passant par des
galères comme toi et moi après moi je
galère encore est-ce que ça compte
[Applaudissements]
distinct que tout le monde va mieux en
tout cas qu'est ce que j'aime bien avec
lui je sais juste qu'il les assume à
fond il en parle sans filtre
aujourd'hui temps n'est pas ton premier
film mais qu'est ce qui t'a donné envie
de faire ce film à et ma taille je
ne vois pas de moi aujourd'hui
dans le film le mans il ya une phrase
qui dit que la douleur que tu as en toi
c'est ça c'est ça qui fait ma force par
exemple n'y a pas de super héros sans
moments sombres exactement la force
c'est ta douleur moi je crois à ça
[Musique]
moi je fais des spectacles sera au
devant d'eux personne pendant vraiment
des années on parle de trois piges de ma
vie où tous les sens j'étais sur mon
structure à chialer avec un juste
cinquante centimètres culturel je ne
ferai pas mg pas la thune pour le faire
réparer j'ai dû faire
plus d'îles casting dans ma vie ouais
j'ai passé tous les mercredis et les
samedis de mes 12 ans à mes 20 ans à
être dans des [ __ ] de salles à
attendre avec un texte de trois pages à
la main à 15 15 autres gars qui je les
fais toute ma vie est toute ma vie on
m'a dit on vous rappellera comment ce
que veut dire ses yeux la c3 et et un
jour je me suis réveillé j'ai dit c'est
pas moi et ça y est vous avez pu le
rappeler ouais je me rappellerai plus
c'est moi je vous rappelle tu commences
tu sais moi parfois ça m'a fait souffrir
aussi georges cette image de mais lui il
est mis la drogue avec une cuillère en
or dans la bouche alors que pas du tout
j'ai en europe qui s'est tapé toute sa
vie pour vendre des téléphones sur les
grands boulevards ma mère elle travaille
à la bnp paribas ne vraiment c'est dans
les bureaux là où ils sont 200 où tous
les jours je l'entendais rentrer à la
maison et j'en peux plus de ce travail
ça me fait souffrir après j'ai commencé
à connaître le succès mais ça a été
super violent j'ai été élevé par mon
grand-père qui ait été un des seuls de
ma famille à croire en ça on dit me
disait bas toi tu vas y arriver il est
décédé juste avant que je commence à
faire ce métier pour moi tu imagines la
souffrance à dire que c'est un mec toute
ta vie c'est le seul de ta famille qui
dit toi tu t'es fait pour ça je vais y
arriver et le mec il décède juste avant
que tout ça arrive il m'a jamais vu sur
scène tu vois
j'ai vécu le divorce de mes parents qui
peut paraître anodin mais c'était quand
j'avais 20 ans un moment très dur très
particulier je commence à avoir du
succès sur scène et en même temps ma
famille partait en lambeaux explosé dans
tous les sens avec mes petits frères qui
étaient très jeunes c'était une grande
souffrance et puis voilà puis tant
d'autres mais j'ai envie de te répondre
comme tout le monde tout le monde a ses
histoires on a tous nos galères on a
tous nos histoires on a tous eu des
soucis et cette souffrance là quand tu
arrives à temps nourrir et en faire une
force je pensais peut t'emmener très
loin me rappelle ma fille que je pars tu
voir donc saddam way qui n'a pas marché
non
comment je fais pour se relever tu perds
un an tu te relèves c'est comme ça j'ai
tout donné pour ce film quand c'est adam
je pense qu'encore aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est un bon film parce que si
demain ils passent à la télé les gens
vont passer un [ __ ] de moments mais
qu'est-ce que faire tu avances j'espère
que ma vision frais plein des cimes il y
en aura des biens et nora des pourris
c'est comme ça c'est la vie c'est pas
grave je suis si j'avais la science
infuse si j'avais le le génie absolu ça
ce serait gelé pas je fais ça avec mon
coeur des fois je vois un film je dis ça
me fait qu'il fait ça me fait galerie
j'ai envie d'y aller j'y vais oui bien
sûr que ça fait du mal les échecs mais
en même temps c'est là que tu apprends
le plus dans les succès et apprend pas
grand chose les succès tout nous est
apte monde vient te csu un bravo ça
c'est un truc super ça veut rien dire un
échec c'est là que tu vois le vrai
visage des gens c'est là que tu vois le
vrai visage du métier ceux qui sont
contents que tu écrases et sexy tu en es
tu en prends
souvent les décisions qui nous amène à
échouer c'est celle qu'on prend en
pleine vitesse le coup de l'émotion
kevin rudd a fait les frais et à cause
de ça il considère qu'il faut
réapprendre à vue c'est vrai j'ai passé
60 ans mais moi ça me parle
est ce que quand pas des échecs je te
dis que tu es allé trop vite parfois
parfois oui moi je parle avec des potes
à moi qui ont entre 25 et 30 piges il
n'y a pas un moment de la journée on
n'est pas en train de faire un truc qui
me disent on fait quoi après
je parle avec les jeunes telle est en
train de t-shirts gijou à la plaie de
feu qu après attend frère jérôme voilà
on est en train de faire un truc bien
parce qu'il ya une espèce de 2,2
d'insuffisance les nouvelles générations
la nouvelle génération celle qui arrive
tu as vu comment ils consomment les
choses tv tik tok ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta faut que ça aille vite faut que
ça aille vite attire mon attention par
toi de là
je pense qu'effectivement faut qu'on
réapprenne à prendre notre temps et à
vivre le moment présent à fond puisque
[ __ ] y'a que ça de vrai on sait pas ni
toit du mois de quoi demain est fait on
sait pas si on arrivera à réaliser leurs
rêves on sait pas si ce qu'on a fait
avant et est bien ou pas bien ce qu'on
sait c'est que la maintenance moment on
est ensemble et qu'il faut le vivre
ainsi il s'agit crois c ou ce que tu dis
parce que en fait je dis tu parles de
réapprendre à vivre et juste avant que
je parlais de ta vie en fait échouer on
a l'impression que c'est la fin de la
vie alors que c'est là en fait on en
apprend plus sur moi c'est bien connu
n'est pas moi qui tu la prends c'est
bien connu c'est quand je prendrai pas
la gueule quand tu tombes quand ils
tombent quand tu tombes qu'au bout d'un
moment tu dis ok je crois j'ai capté
jouera là j'ai compris quelque chose
thomas edison il a déposé un talent
brevet avant d'inventer l'ampoulé
électrique les échecs servent de
répétition succès en fait pour faire
court les chèques seul fondement de la
réussite qu'a ville apparemment telle
ampoule électrique il a mis du temps
avant de voir la lumière
est-ce que tu as peur de la mort du
futur en finale
j'ai peur de la mort du futur mans non
j'ai pas peur du futur moi je crois
profondément à ça je chacun ses
croyances mois pour moi dieu est aux
commandes les choses se font comme elles
doivent se faire ce que je veux dire
c'est que il faut pas forcer les choses
nous par contre se réveiller tous les
matins en se disant j'y vais j'ai les
crocs je vais rien lâcher et une fois
que casas tout le reste ne dépend plus
vraiment de toi je comprends tout le
reste dépend de l'énergie que tu va
déployer que tu va envoyer et si ça paye
c'est bien si ça paye pas ça va venir
voilà comment moi je vois les choses
j'ose le dire que pour moi et pour moi
c'est soit ça j'y arrive je recommence
quoi
je vous
commencé comme ça je comme ça depuis
tout petit c'est jazz recommence pour ça
que des fois je vois des injustices des
voiliers des gens qui me disent des
journalistes mais c'est plus facile pour
vous vous êtes devenu star à 18 ans si
facile qu'il faut
tout comme à 10 ans j'étais déjà un ouf
dans ma tête à 10 ans jeudi était déjà
en mode comment je vais y arriver [ __ ]
comment c'est tout mais sinon j'ai
galéré comme tout le monde j'ai eu des
coups durs comme tout le monde j'aurai
dans le futur des échecs et des succès
comme tout le monde je suis pas plus ou
moins qu'un autre mais par contre je
lâcherais ap ça c'est sûr
- franchement par l'échec avec elle
c'est du lourd on s'envoie des bons
messages de motivation ça c'est cool
mais j'ai oublié un truc en fait mais tu
connais on apprend le métier orné des
débutants à la pâte et d'écoles vous moi
ce qui m'intéressait c'est par les loges
ça aura plus tu es comment sont restés
volatils voix et franchement je
m'attendais pas à ça
est-ce que c'est plus facile maintenant
ou avant
les amours franchement je n'ai pas de
réponse à cette question je sais pas je
sais pas j'ai même l'impression que
le statut d'eurostat parfois c'est même
presque handicapant quand tu vois et
puisque ça existe vraiment encore moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya plus de stars
dans notre époque tu vois j'ai
l'impression que de moins en moins
regardons regarder ses rides éthylique
je sais pas comment il s'appelle les
gars d'en laisser allemand et tous les
adore et tu kiffes la série je pense
qu'on est amené à se diriger vers un
monde où il y aura moins cette espèce de
vedettariat reconnu un côté weya les
vedettes pelé - veut d'être fâché avec
mon frère on marche dans la rue dit à
vue qui s'est
dit sceptique mach 6 équipe 6
millions sur tik tok il fait pas un seul
type toi que tu pas des millions de vues
je sais pas qui c'est je sais pas qui
c'est et je lui dis c'est quoi le talent
de tish mac ne dit rien il reprend des
sons il fait des cap sur les murs
mais je rencontre un mec de 15 entre 15
et 25 ans dans la rue me dis oh [ __ ] 6
millions sur 1 stabaek c'est lourd c'est
lourd c'est à dire que pour lui
c'est un accomplissement je comprends ce
que dira ça veut dire quelque chose et
dans ce monde là moi j'essaye de jouer
le jeu parce que je pense que si tu vas
contre ça ouais ben t'es tu es morte a
perdu et moi j'aime trop ce métier pour
l'arrêter donc donc j'essaie de jouer le
jeu
je donne un petit stock donne un peu
d'un stage de la faute aux jeux de turin
j'essaye de donner un peu de chemin
twitter l'egypte donne un peu léger
pour attirer vers des projets qui me
tiennent réellement que si je commence à
être en mode arrêt sans signe ou les
arts à ce qui se passe vous avez maintes
est mort
soit tu joues le jeu soit est out et
même si tu veux faire une belle chance
d'être out selon pas longtemps quoi
comme ça sans savoir ce que les bleus
merci beaucoup quel avec les objets de
leur plaisir
je suis assez parce que franchement
chicago tu vois les petits biscuits dans
les restaurants chinois avec un petit
message à l'intérieur un jour j'en ai
ouvert un kids est comme ça l'échec est
la mère du succès au passage dédicaces
ateliers maman et à la mienne force à
toi pas facile d'avoir un fils comme moi
mais bon on fait avec ce qu'on a
à toi et à vous qui vous regardez croyez
en vous priant de vos rêves et je vous
souhaite un taux d'échec parce que c'est
comme ça que la réussite à venir
ah oui j'oubliais abonne toi la chaîne
route et si tu as des personnes que tu
veux je contacte à un influenceur que
chip east j'aï lui parler tu as un
symbôle heures tu veux je lui parle tu
as un danseur tu veux juste pantin
président tu veux que je lui parle on
vend moins dé m mais en commentaires sur
youtube peu importe mais bien on discute
ensemble vient on parle bien c'est notre
chaîne vient on se lave débat est bien
c'est que nous à
[Musique]